she
had
£18,000 in baby milk tins wrapped up in
duct tape hidden in her house ready for
what ready for this guy
to put a brick across the Brack of my
head that's when it got really
[Music]
scary what was your upbringing like I
was uh an academic child I did what I
was told I was um I was happy to to work
hard um trying to make the most of
things I think uh trying to make my
parents proud of me University was great
I really made the most of of certainly
of the first year um it was I took the
opportunity to be a completely different
person come the second year that's when
I I met Victoria um things started off
really well
when you first met Victoria why were you
drawn to her what was she like she was
bubbly enthusiastic she was
um she was really exciting she
represented um somebody who
was interesting and interested um she
was very interested in me and things
started to get very intense um very
quickly it was intense it was a new
relationship we were in each other's po
as it went on and that continued there
was no there's no letup it it it didn't
stop being that by the end of the second
year it was a it was that times 100 it
had moved from being around each other
all the time to being around each other
with nobody else all the time there were
there were people who who said to
me
are you sure things are things are are
things
okay but it's very difficult for me for
I think for for for men and young men in
particular to say no it's not okay I
don't like it at at the time I I didn't
know what an abusive relationship looked
like for me I recognized now that that's
what it was um in the way in which there
was uh I was
controlled in the way in which I was
maneuvered manipulated the term coercive
control didn't exist um certainly not
for me I didn't know what that was and
whether or not why that would even be
applicable to me um the way in which
things were created
to be my opinion um I didn't have an
opinion other than our opinion I didn't
make any decisions it was very difficult
to and that's very difficult to explain
because when I met people I was making
decisions all the time but those
decisions were always couched with well
what would Victoria prefer me to do what
does she want me to do I stayed after
University for another year while she
finished her course and we moved in um
to a separate house together and that
gave us a reason not to see anybody
almost and I couldn't go anywhere
without first making sure that she was
happy for me to go or for us both to go
um and that kind
of total control um was certainly
something
that became became part and parcel of of
who I was and the and who we were as as
a as a couple so she was insisting that
it would just be you two it was all on
her terms there was always a reason
there was always a
justification you know if if I if I
loved her
then why do we need to go
out you know what's the point she was my
life she
was my
reason and that's what she wanted every
single step is a small step every single
move is entirely reasonable it's um you
know going to college going to
University going to work and then all of
a sudden you turn around and you realize
that's all you're doing you're you're
going to work and then coming home and
not doing anything else there's there's
no there is no social life there is no
um reason to do anything or be anywhere
other than with her and so again it was
a one of those small incremental log
iCal steps um we were together we were
married then we have
kids so I was I was 26 when uh when my
daughter was
born and all of us sudden you know
Victoria got pushed to Second Place um
and she didn't like
that how long were you in this
relationship with
Victoria um in total so we met in 20 um
we met in
1999 um and uh I separated after my um
my daughter was about 1 and a half so
about uh 2007 middle of 2007 towards the
end of
2007 so once you decided to leave the
relationship how did Victoria
immediately
respond for a short time everything was
okay
um in the same way that everything was
was okay when we got together it didn't
last long um because I left and she was
very angry about that and
she perhaps wanted to to exact
some level of punishment some level of
reestablish some level of control things
started to to ramp up I started getting
requests which were
more and more
extreme um I would be asked to
travel 2 hours on a on the drop of a hat
in order to see my
daughter um for a day and then and then
bring her back or plans would change
halfway through that and say well now
she's no longer there she's here um I
would be shut out from various decisions
I had to make a decision that I had to
put everything
else second and put her and put my
daughter first and that's what I
did that's the point at which everything
started to go wrong Victoria was
remarried her husband she had told
him that I had hurt her she had let him
know in KN un certain terms how
dangerous I was I think his what he did
next was naive
and and a shame um he attacked my car
and set fire to my car and set fire to
my house and so what he did was
wrong um and what he did put my life and
the life of my family in in
danger but the way the decision
that that got him to that place was
exactly the same decision
process that she
had
perfected on
me and with Wayne he attacked your house
how did he get caught for that and how
come she didn't end up in in prison for
that they were both
arrested um she was released without
charge um she wasn't there um she
couldn't be placed
and of course the other thing is is that
Wayne
never never described that she
was um connected in any way um he denied
uh even doing it
himself um he was he was convicted of it
but he always he plead he pleed not
guilty um and
um as as a result they the police didn't
and couldn't connect Victoria to it they
there was several pieces of of evidence
um that connected Wayne not least a
recording um a 999 recording um that
connected him to to the
case so she tried to persuade a series
of men to murder you essentially like
what was her r and how was she
persuading
them um the the the modus
operand was was the same um to paint me
as a as a person as a terrible human
being as as worthy of punishment as
worthy of um being dealt
with Victoria was was able to um move
and manipulate relationships and
conversations and
friendships uh incredibly easily
depending on on the the type of of
people that she spoke to varying degrees
of
success thankfully for me some of these
guys of
course said that they didn't want to
have any part of it
um and and some were
more open to the suggestion once these
guys had said
no then she moved on and and got and
found somebody else who would be who she
thought might be willing to to do it and
that's how we moved on through um in the
end it was five five guys that that I am
aware
of
the way in which Victoria was was
recorded
um by talking to somebody
who by all accounts seemed to be far
more professional certainly purported to
be more professional than any of the
other guys that she had spoken to prices
were discussed methods were discussed
that recording was then put to trial um
she pleaded not guilty she said that it
was a um a joke it's she said that it
was a you know a way in which to let off
steam against an old ex and in abusive
relationships which I now recognize mine
was it's always the
pattern that gives it away and her
pattern was this it wasn't one joke it
wasn't one thing it it was the
sustained series of actions the series
of
intentions that took us to a point where
she
had
£18,000 in baby milk tins wrapped up in
duct tape hidden in her
house ready for
what ready for this guy
to put a brick across the back of my
head
that's when it got really scary the
trial was
um two weeks of very difficult very
difficult events I was expecting to be
called um to give evidence but but I
wasn't um I was really
surprised that actually the defense took
my statement and and and just agreed
finally at last someone believed me
someone
could stand up and
say yes that happened and it happened to
you that was an
incredibly fulfilling feeling it it it
it meant probably more than almost
anything else okay I was an extreme
example but I I wasn't the only example
you know there are lots of um aspects of
my story that that are applicable to
lots of
different men women reaching those
people reaching those guys reaching the
guys who don't think that they're in
that kind of difficult
relationship recognition that it is a
problem is one step it's difficult to
ask for
help and finding someone who you trust
to ask for
help but there are more and more people
out out there
connections that can
help talk to anyone talk to the people
at the bus stop talk
to friends family
anybody but talk to
somebody how do you feel towards
Victoria
now I
feel I feel that she
has
wasted so much opportunity I'm not going
to give her
the control and the power
to keep on affecting me and and and our
life in the way that she was for a very
long
time we have made a a beautiful young
lady who is looking at the rest of her
life with anticipation with excitement
um and it is a wasted opportunity a
shame that that she has missed that
and that is something that she has to
live with that's her life
sentence he looked young he did look
young but it was after the the marriage
that I knew that he was twice my age so
I was 50 and he was 30 I knew I knew who
was going to rape me and that's what
happened
and it it became like every single day